these actors stunt workers and crew
members showed up for what they thought
was just another day at work
only to lose their lives in some of the
most bizarre ways imaginable
veteran english actor oliver reed died
before finishing all of his scenes for
ridley scott's 2000
epic gladiator this forced scott to
engage in some digital trickery with
outtakes to depict the death of reed's
character
gladiator handler proximo but the
circumstances surrounding reed's death
served to illustrate two things about
the man
he was every bit as tough as his
on-screen persona suggested
and he was a bit too fond of liquor for
his own good
the film was shot on location in malta
and on the night before he was to shoot
his final scenes
reed celebrated by dropping in on a
local pub he put down eight pints of
lager before moving on to a dozen double
shots of rum
and a half bottle of whiskey then he
proceeded to take on a crew of british
navy sailors in an
arm wrestling contest defeating them all
before finally preparing to retire for
the night
but after decades of such behavior
reid's body had finally had enough
he suffered a massive heart attack and
dropped dead on the spot
the pub where he died has come to be
known as ollie's last pub
fans the world over come through to
browse its collection of memorabilia
have a pinter three and pay tribute to
one of the most legendary tough guys in
film history
veteran character actor vic morrow was
cast as a bigot who gets a taste of his
own medicine in time out
the first segment of 1983's twilight
zone the movie
tragically the role would be morrow's
last and the accident that killed him in
two others was among the most gruesome
in film history
in the scene which was cut from the
final film moro's character tries to
carry two
children to safety through a vietnamese
swamp while a helicopter bombs their
village
during a rehearsal take the pyrotechnics
buffeted pilot dorsey wingo's helicopter
scaring him senseless
but director john landis insisted on
shooting the scene as rehearsed and
wingo didn't challenge him as cameras
rolled
the explosions forced wingo to set his
chopper down
right in the middle of the set one of
its skids crushed six-year-old child
actor renee chen
while moro and seven-year-old mika denle
were both decapitated by its main blade
the accident resulted in landis wingo
and three
others being put on trial for
involuntary manslaughter
though they were acquitted in 1987.
veteran english character actor roy
kinnear was perhaps best known for
playing the father of spoiled little
veruca salt
in 1971's willy wonka and the chocolate
factory
but his complete list of credits is
longer than your arm among them were the
1973 version of the three musketeers and
its 1989 sequel
the return of the musketeers both
directed by kinnear's frequent
collaborator richard lester
alas the latter ended up being his final
role
kaneer was injured in a fall from a
horse during the shoot in spain
and he was subsequently admitted to a
hospital in madrid his injuries weren't
considered life-threatening
but they were apparently too much for
his body he suffered a heart attack the
next day while still in the hospital
and doctors weren't able to save him
kneer's untimely death had a profound
effect on the film's cast and crew
but none were so affected as lester who
had lost a dear friend
1987's million dollar mystery was as
much a gimmick as it was a film
it's cast of zany characters spent the
entire run time hunting down a series of
three cash dashes of 1 million dollars
hidden somewhere in the united states
the ending revealed the third stash of
hidden loot was totally real
as it challenged audiences to use clues
from the film to determine its location
the movie was widely ignored when it
wasn't being roundly panned
but its most unfortunate legacy lies in
the accident that took the life of
stuntman dar robinson
widely considered by his peers to be one
of the gutsiest stunt workers
alive robinson held a number of insane
records
including the highest fall ever put on
film he had somehow never suffered an
onset injury in his career but that
changed in the most tragic fashion
possible during the shooting of a
routine motorcycle chase sequence
robinson went into a curve at a high
speed on his honda 600 dirt bike
losing control and skidding off the road
he was separated from his bike
thrown down an embankment and impaled by
a sagebrush branch
he was airlifted to a hospital but his
injuries ended up killing him
john jordan was among the most fearless
camera operators who ever lived
having developed his own perilous
technique of getting the kind of aerial
shots that simply shouldn't have been
possible secured only by a harness with
his feet resting on the skid of a
helicopter
he would lean out into the blue to
secure his amazing shots
it was during the filming of one such
aerial sequence for the james bond film
you only live twice
that he came a little too close to one
of his subjects
a bell 47 helicopter one of its blades
struck and
almost removed his foot which eventually
had to be amputated
but jordan was undeterred and he went
right back to work doing what he did
best
the gung-ho attitude finally caught up
with him in 1969 while shooting catch-22
jordan was acting as a second unit
director shooting from the open door of
a b-25 bomber
once again a passing aircraft got a
little too close
but rather than making contact it
created a freak gust of wind that threw
the b-25
off to one side jordan lost his balance
got too close to the door
and was promptly sucked out he plummeted
to his death
4 000 feet into the ocean while not a
household name
director actor and stunt driver toby
halicki won himself a cult following in
the 1970s by virtue of being
preternaturally gifted at the art of
filming car chases and crashes
his sophomore effort 1974 is gone in 60
seconds
is a prime example of this gift but
during the filming of its 1989 sequel
heliki met his end in a bizarre accident
that strangely had nothing to do with
his insanely dangerous
stunt work while filming in tonawanda
new york the crew was setting
up to shoot the collapse of a water
tower for a scene that tawanda officials
had tried
mightily to prevent paliki had been
forced to take out an
8 million dollar insurance policy in
order to get them to relent
and he had announced his plans to sue
the city upon the film's completion
but as it turned out he probably should
have paid more attention to their
concerns
the tower collapsed prematurely causing
an attached steel cable to snap
the cable then knocked over a nearby
telephone pole which fell directly on
top of hilicky
he was treated by emts at the scenes in
no avail and was pronounced
dead on arrival at the local hospital
halicki's widow denise served as an
executive producer on the 2000 remake of
gone in 60 seconds as a means of
preserving her husband's legacy
2008's the dark knight featured some
incredible stunt work in conjunction
with spectacular and sometimes dangerous
practical effects
among the stunt workers working on the
film was conway wickliffe
a 41 year old veteran of the industry
while shooting a portion of the tumbler
bat cycle chase sequence
wycliffe was in the process of capturing
a fairly standard shot when tragedy
struck
he was filming a stunt car while hanging
out the window of an suv
his vehicle's driver inexplicably veered
off course
failing to follow his prescribed route
and instead plowing through a grassy
area
a detour that ended with a crash into a
tree despite the fact that the suv was
only going about 20 miles per hour
wickliffe suffered injuries serious
enough that he was pronounced
dead at the scene his untimely demise
was
unfortunately a harbinger of things to
come
as star heath ledger died of an
accidental drug overdose shortly before
the film's release
the shocking deaths of both men were
memorialized in the dark knight's
closing credits
in 1978 residents of lexington kentucky
were thrilled to have a real hollywood
production in town
it was steel starring and produced by
lexington native lee majors
the film's climax called for its villain
to plummet from a skyscraper to his
death
and the city's kincaid towers which were
nearing completion were just the ticket
the fall was performed by 27 year old aj
bakunis
who at one time held the record for the
highest fall and the scene had been
completed with bakunis jumping from the
ninth story into an airbag
but then bokunis got word that dar
robinson had recently broken his record
causing him to insist on shooting the
scene again making the jump from the top
of the 323 foot tower this time
the onset physician tried desperately to
halt the attempt
but bucuna's intent on regaining his
record wouldn't change his mind
he performed the fall and struck the
airbag squarely in the prescribed area
only to have it rupture amazingly
despite having just fallen hundreds of
feet essentially onto concrete
bucunus initially clung to life but
although his head and internal organs
had escaped serious injury
his lungs had taken too much damage he
died the next day
in february 2014 a 20-person film crew
showed up for work on the biopic
midnight writer
the life story of rocker greg allman
director randall miller had them shoot
scenes on an
active train track assuring them that it
was in use only by two trains both of
which
had already gone by in the unlikely
event that another train appeared they
were told they'd have only 60 seconds to
clear the track
that ended up being not nearly enough
time as a third train made an
unexpected appearance in the middle of
the shoot the locomotive was traveling
at a speed close to 60 miles per hour it
struck a bed which had been affixed to
the tracks
sending debris flying 27 year old camera
operator sarah jones was somehow pushed
into the path of the train
which struck and killed her instantly
miller subsequently became the first
filmmaker to be convicted on a criminal
charge
related to events on a film set he pled
guilty to involuntary manslaughter
and was sentenced to two years in prison
with eight years of probation to follow
while midnight rider was cancelled